let me tell you something that's that's
substantive though i want to talk about
this story right here the first thing i
want to do is show you this clip where i
said holy ish they want war they profit
from war listen to this from joe biden
so i think what you're going to say hold
on let me make sure i get the audio
right because it may be playing properly
but i'm just going to double check our
sources real quick and now i'm going to
play it okay here we go
so i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having a fight about
what to do and not do etc
it depends on what it does if it's a
minor incursion yeah and a lot of people
immediately went like why would you
downplay the u.s response to russia
invading another country in europe
because limited war baby henry
kissinger's let's do proxy wars and take
little pieces of this and that they've
segmented it into china russia and the
u.s three superpowers get to split the
earth amongst them you're absolutely
correct well the british are also on
that list they're absolutely correct
they're like limited war we've accepted
it uh final answer elaborate right now
well the proxy wars that are happening
are very profitable especially when you
have these big major kind of states
fighting each other the west versus the
east and they already happen in syria
they already happened in yemen and if
they could advance it towards another
place like ukraine this only of course
benefits the military-industrial complex
now this could be a two-prong response
here understanding uh biden's statements
one is that he's old he see now he
doesn't know what he's talking about the
second one is that he's inviting russia
in because at the long term this is
going to work in favor of the
neoconservative of the deep state of the
military or the industrial complex that
of course is going to be striving for
this but there's two other uh important
pieces of information to consider here a
couple weeks ago the biden
administration according to some sources
even went to ukraine and said would it
be okay if you just give up some of your
uh sovereign land to to russia so this
is something that has already been an
underlining policy that has happened
before so that's why i'm also calling
bunk on the white house's latest
statement because they just issued a
clarification on biden's statement
saying that if russia invades of course
there's going to be a swift and severe
response and obviously they're just
trying to cover the bad press and the
bad reaction they're getting from this
but geopolitically the situation is
complex russia has been moving their
troops towards ukraine the united states
and nato have been moving their troops
towards russia as well so the situation
is getting tense and i wouldn't be
surprised if there was another proxy war
that of course is going to be perpetual
warfare as ian said the henry kissinger
doctrine never-ending war for profit
just want to show this cnn headline real
quick
biden predicts russia will move into
ukraine but says minor incursion may
prompt discussion over consequences wow
even cnn couldn't sugarcoat that one
although they tried though right now
that was a this is cnn moment you know
look i want to agree with some of you
said a moment ago about the the
expansion on the the military side if
you went back and listened to biden's
answer he said in fact we're already
going to increase the number of troops
that we have he said poland and then he
also uh the other country for the other
country you mentioned be list
two countries and then he goes if they
go and move into ukraine and do some
different things but he was all ready to
i mean that's the thing that no one's
talking about he already announced u.s
troop expansions uh into two different
countries as part of his answer like
he's already thought through this i mean
he definitely has the direction he wants
to go but you know one of the points i'd
make a little bit of the buried lead on
this when we see whether it's putin or
she which i spent a lot of time talking
about the ccp and what they're doing
around the world as soon as biden was
declared the winner that's when these
guys started going on the offense and
the real reason why we know that i think
both biden or excuse me but she and
putin take action is if biden's the
one-term president they're gonna go and
make their moves now while he's in as
opposed to waiting till whoever comes
next do you remember when biden was i
think you said a u.n meeting or was a g7
and he kept saying libya over and over
again instead of syria
i i assure you she and and putin see
that and they look at each other and you
know putin's like is she if we invade
ukraine he might accidentally invade
libya instead
so but you think it's a you know i'm
half joking imagine if if joe biden is
in the situation room
and he says directly to to his generals
we gotta we gotta get more more troops
on the ground in libya you get get to it
and like sir do you mean you heard me
and they're like okay he got a lot wrong
why but but here's the important people
to understand
if the generals hear joe biden say libya
and they leave saying well we know he
really meant syria so we'll go with
syria instead what if he really did mean
libya
if he did mean syria when he said libya
and the generals say you your order is
sir and then they start sending troops
to libya what
i'm sorry man i understand that joe
biden misspoke but he said true not a
shabbat of pressure and batacaf care as
well
you got to be very precise when you're
talking about missile strikes and nukes
and war and i'm pretty sure putin she
and even you know kim jong-un and any
one of our adversaries you know in iran
and venezuela are like there's a good
chance that if we invade joe biden will
order a missile strike in the wrong
country let's go for it i i disagree
there uh because putin realizes that the
president isn't really the president of
the united states he made very important
comments a couple years ago specifically
talking about how even presidents change
there's always men in dark suits that
implement the same kind of foreign
policy that has been in some ways always
the same
for a very long time for decades now and
it's important to understand i think
he's just a puppet i think the
military-industrial complex knows
exactly what they're doing the language
from the biden administration and
intelligence agencies has been concise
here and they said russia will stage a
false flag attack and will launch an
invasion of russia it's only a matter of
time until russia invades ukraine russia
will invade ukraine those are the
talking points of the intelligence
agency of the biden administration right
after the cia had just had a secret
mission in kiev where he came back from
and this information came uh came out
that they're going to do a false flag
and many people are speculating that
kiev gave the head of the cia this
information the cia gave it to cnn and
that's why the american public has now
regurgitated this information false
flags have always started a lot of world
wars uh and important wars throughout
recorded human history so there's
there's the rhetoric is hot here and
it's and it's pretty crazy i don't know
if it'll be world war three but i think
i'd be willing to bet within this year
russia invades ukraine joe biden says
something like trinidad shabbat of
pressure but it's because there's a plan
in action and we don't know he's
muttering about but we do respond and
this is i think because the democrats
are losing many are retiring joe biden's
approval rating is in the absolute is
just destroyed and they need a
distraction and they need something to
try and boost their approval ratings and
offer up something not just really quick
i'm not saying there's going to be a
world war but i'm saying the only thing
as you were saying i was going to make
that point the only thing that could
stop the negative viewpoint of the biden
administration the the poll numbers is a
conflict is a war and i don't see it as
as uh because there's mutual absurd uh
assured destruction if russia and the
united states fight each other it's
going to be just like syria the united
states is going to be sending more arms
sending in more uh you know military
hardware more u.s tax paying dollars
will be sent to ukraine russia will of
course influence that region they
already have been fighting for years now
so it's only
it only makes sense that the conflict's
escalating and is going to ask so
this is one of the things to remember
the contrast between biden and trump for
example is biden tonight very much
sounded like a u.s senator he didn't
sound like a president sounded like a
senator so when he was talking about
even their domestic agenda he's going
through i like this part of legislation
not that i'm going to try to save this
part not the other he went through and
gave this very kind of methodology he
walked himself into the trap was he
tried to turn to nuance and give his
answer about we'll see on the minor
incursion all of that i mean obviously
we know the last time that putin went
rolling into ukraine i mean he took
crimea back i mean so they already have
the precedent that biden's not going to
do anything so i think what happens is
putin definitely goes i don't think it's
a full takeover of ukraine but it's
enough to rattle the saber make himself
look good at home biden says well i'm
going to give you double triple secret
sanctions uh and effectively then putin
wins the day and biden looks weak but i
think they know that biden is uh we're
as opposed to trump who basically told
uh well obviously with putin he took one
strategy of kind of doing the buddy
routine with kim jong-un and he said
fire and fury will drop the bombs and
wipe you off the face of the earth guess
what deter kim jong-un quite a bit
absolutely ian you had something to say
yeah this is why i think limited war and
not total war this is the kissinger
limited war doctrine where they wanna
they want conflict not in the homeland
because you don't wanna destroy your
infrastructure and they don't wanna go
to nukes with russia so they'd like to
just military industrial complex the
hell out of ukraine
buy and sell a lot of weapons destroy a
lot of bombs over cities and just level
i mean that's what they did in vietnam
that was a limited war they didn't want
to go to war with russia or china and
this has been building for a very long
time especially with the united states
trying to build their sphere of
influence trying to get ukraine from
russian influence towards a european
nato influence we saw john mccain in
kiev literally lead the marches down
there trying to overthrow their
government there was a very violent
revolution that hurt a lot of people it
was all against corruption the ukrainian
people were dealing with a corrupt
government but they got another corrupt
government in response to it with
biden's fingerprints all over it with
his sons business involvements in it and
of course also the president of the
united states donald trump at the time
who sent lethal weapons to ukraine which
was an absolute huge escalation
according to russia and this is why
russia is pissed off because they're
seeing nato they're seeing the us
weapons going closer and closer to their
border and they're saying we need to
strike back in order to push back
against this nonsense the secretary of
state even a couple weeks ago said nato
never agreed not to build up on on
russia's border which is absolutely
untrue there's a lot of documents
there's a lot of agreements between
russia and nato and the united states
saying that the united states won't be
building up a lot of their military
hardware on there so this is a very
escalating uh hot situation that could
turn very drastic for the people of
ukraine which is absolutely sad as these
but isn't it better politicians just
rule lives which is insane i think
trump's strategy with sending weapons to
ukraine was hey we're not going to get
involved in this conflict we'll sell you
some weapons it's all on you whereas
biden and the neolibs and neocons were
setting up you know getting hunter biden
in barisma trying to work you know
energy
companies there's a reason why they want
to get ukraine into you know
aligned with the western forces trump's
attitude was america first we don't want
to be at war with these countries here
are some weapons it's your issue yeah i
mean take a look at me do you think
germany or france or anyone else in nato
was watching biden tonight a were they
you know not laughing or shaking their
head and be like what the blank is this
or shaking in their boots exactly or
saying exactly the same this thing they
don't have our back bring trump back can
we get trump back in the white house i
mean that's where i mean you know that
uh um you know the mcr you know when you
have macron and johnson and even though
angela uh has left um olaf schultz i'm
sure they're like let's get trump back
at least we knew where that guy stood
well well biden continued trump's
policies of providing lethal weapons to
ukraine so that also is escalating the
situation it's it's a very complex
situation because we should actually see
it from both perspectives we should see
it from the russian side from the
ukrainian side and from the american
side because each side has their own
particular version of events i'm trying
to just tell people the version of
events how i see it but again there's
different pr there's different
propaganda from each different side and
it's truly a very dangerous situation
that i believe will be a limited war
just like ian is saying with the henry
kissinger doctrine that makes most sense
but even with that there still is a
probability of it escalating and
becoming extremely dangerous for
everyone else and that's why war should
never be the answer diplomacy should be
the way to move forward here thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you